Man: Another really
great use case for proxies is
when you are building a library
that other developers are going
to use, you need to implement
some sort of ergonomics so that
they are going to use it with
the greatest ease possible. This
is something that I run into all
the time. It drives me
bonkers that, when you have a
map and you want to set the
longitude, people have a hard
time deciding on if the
property's going to be longitude,
or they're going to spell it
wrong, or you use L-O-N-G or L-O-
N. Finally at the end of the day
they realize "OK, it's LNG," but
that might be half an hour of
debugging to realize that's such
a silly mistake. Same thing
goes with CamelCasing or
something like that where you
have a property like ID. People
don't know if identification
should be CamelCased -- it
shouldn't -- or if it's all
uppercase -- it shouldn't -- or
if it's just lower case.
Something like that, so it
really is helpful when you're
making something to check.
Are people making any of these
common mistakes, or is someone
setting a property where there
is an existing property already
that is in a different case like
that? Then maybe we should
actually warn them. Let's take
an example with this. I'm going
to delete this, and we're going
to make a new safety object.
I'm going to start with an
object here, and we'll put an ID
of 100 in there. Then we also
need a handler, so we'll create
the handler and call it "Safe
handler". It's an object. We'll
take that object and pop it into
here. Now the way we're going to
test this is we're going to go
down here and say "safety.id=200."
If someone tries to change the
ID and they're using a different
case than what we initially
intended, then we should throw
an error in actually one of them.
We only need to trap the set
here. The get doesn't really
matter to us, and neither do any
of the other traps. We just want
the set value, which will take a
target, a name, and a value.
Now here what we want to do is
make a list of like keys, so
we're going to make them all
lower case. We can use "object
at keys" to get a list of all of
the keys off of the current
object. Then I'm just going to
find all of the like keys that
are equal to the one that the
person is looking for but in
lowercase. It's equal
to name.2 lower case. The
reason I did two lower case on
both of them is so that we have
apples to apples here, and we're
not trying to check against all
of the other ones. If someone
passes Wes and our key
is Wes, then we know that
there's a difference, or if
someone passes Wes and our key
is Wes, you know that there's a
difference. That just covers
every single possible use case
for us if we normalize them all
to lower case here. Now we say, "
If there is no name in the
target, if they are trying to
set a new property, which
setting uppercase ID would be a
new property because the
existing property is lowercase
ID, and there is a like key.
There is a key that is like ID,
but it's in uppercase. That's
what this did right here. We
checked for that. If that's the
case, then we just want to throw
a new error. We'll tell them, "
Oops. Looks like we already have
a property but with a case of..."
You use template strings to put
the name in there, like he.
Otherwise, if that doesn't
happen, then we'll just go along
with our lives and set the key
for them because that's what we
actually wanted. Good. Now I
should be able to refresh this,
and we get an error. Oops. Looks
like we already have an ID
property but with the case of
lower case ID. Let's try it
again. We'll say, "safety.name=
Wes". That works just fine. Then
if I try to update the name to
Wesley, but maybe I spell it
with a capital N for whatever
reason, it's going to yell at me. "
Looks like we already have a
name property but with a case of
name." It's not going to go
through and update it. You can
really help out other developers
that are using it. By thinking
ahead of these things, you can
cut down on get-hub issues,
emails, and all that kind of
stuff if you make your proxies a
little bit more resilient.